اقاله وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي هي ازمه
داخل الازمه دفعت بالاف الغاضبين الى
الشارع الذي يعيش منذ مده على ايقاع
الاحتجاجات على التعديلات القضائيه تفعل
الاعلام الاسرائيلي مع موجه الغضب التي
خلفت الاقاله ونقل غضب الشارع
لقد وجه رئيس الحكومه اليوم ضربه مؤلمه
لامن الدوله ولذلك لا يمكنه ان يستمر في
وظيفته نحن مستمرون حتى اسقاط الحكومه
يكفي لقد مللنا نحن نموت هنا وهم لا
يهتمون الا بالحفاظ على بيبي في الحكم ما
يهمهم هو الانقلاب دون ان يحاوروا احدا
نطخ خلال جلسات النقاش يحضر عسكريون
سابقون ولا يتردد بعضهم في مقارنه ما يجري
بموجه الربيع العربي التي يسمونها
انقلابات
نحن نعيش ليله تاريخيه ودراماتيكيه نعيش
ازمه كبيره لم نشهد لها مثيلا الصور التي
نراها تذكرني بصور دول عربيه مجاوره خلال
الانقلابات خرجت الجماهير الفقيره لانها
رات رئيس الحكومه يفضل اخراس وزير الامن
وفصله على الامن القومي
بدلوهم في هذا النقاش ولا يترددون ايضا في
التحذير من خطوره الاحداث التي تشهدها
اسرائيل
الدوله في خطر دوله اسرائيل تعيش الخطر
الاعظم منذ حرب يوم الغفران خطر اقتصادي
يهدد كل شيء وخطر سياسي وبالاساس خطر امني
يذهبوا محللنا كثر في الاعلام الاسرائيلي
الى ان اسرائيل لم تعش خطرا داخليا كهذا
من قبل ويحذرون بنيامين نتنياهو من
الاستمرار في نهجه الحالي
اعتقد ان بامكاننا الاشاره الى علامات
الوضع السيء الذي نعيشه التهديد الكبير
الذي كنا نخشاه من الخارج اصبح الان
تهديدا داخليا علينا ان نظهر موقفا صلبا
وموحدا للخارج حتى لا نجعل اعداءنا كايران
وحماس يعتقدون اننا نعاني ضعفا داخليا
تذهب تحليلات كثير من وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه في اتجاه التحذير من الشرخ
الذي تشهده اسرائيل وتاثيره على صورتها في
المنطقه والعالم